so what the previous verses series doing
so well what I wanted to do here is try
something a little more unique and pip
Thanos with the Infinity Gauntlet
against one punch man asking the
question who would win if the two men
what also want to point out here is that
like the other videos we're going to be
focusing on four main ideas strength
agility intelligence and weakness
so beginning with strength despite
looking like an ordinary person one
punch man has immense physical strength
in his various comics he's shown that he
can make most of his enemies explode
with a single punch and has launched
himself through a city sized meteor
before his character is so tough in fact
that he was knocked to the moon once by
Lord burrows the leader of a group of
alien invaders and one punch man was
able to use his jumping power to return
to earth nearly immediately in addition
to this his punch is so strong that he's
deflected and attacked from a beam that
could destroy the earth however the true
measure of his physical strength is
unknown as he's yet to encounter enemy
they can withstand more than one punch
from him on the other hand without the
Infinity Gauntlet Thanos has cosmic
level strength having fought the likes
of Galactus Silver Surfer and The
Incredible Hulk with the Infinity
Gauntlet Thanos proved capable of
completely toying with and dominating
all the existing superheroes and cosmic
entities of the mainstream Marvel
Universe imprisoning them and placing
himself at the peak of absolute power
now focusing on their agility one punch
man has nearly immeasurable speed able
to complete a 1500 meter dash in an
instant he was even able to keep up with
speed of sound sonic a villain and
occasional antihero who could move at
hypersonic speeds going so fast that he
leaves an afterimage when he moves for
Thanos however despite his bulky form
and without the Infinity Gauntlet he's
able to run faster than Olympic level
athletes with the Infinity Gauntlet he
was able to be everywhere at once
something to note here though is it
Thanos his incredible speed with the
Infinity Gauntlet was a byproduct of
manipulating space itself using the
space gym now focusing on their
intelligence one punch man is not known
to have a great intellect and in fact he
barely passed a superhero exam to do his
below average intelligence on the other
hand the Infinity Gauntlet doesn't do
much for Thanos here with the exception
of the mind gym which allows him to read
and control the minds of all sentient
beings in the universe however this does
not mean that OSes unintelligent and
truth with or without the gauntlet he's
actually a genius in virtually all known
fields of advanced science and his
created technology exceeding modern
earth scientists like
Richards Tony Stark Bruce Banner Amadeus
Cho and Black Panther moving on to
weaknesses this is probably the most
important category one punch man's
weaknesses aren't highly detailed except
for his below average intelligence in a
version two mosquitoes and a requirement
to breathe oxygen something to also note
is that where he does have super senses
he has shown an ability to be taken by
surprise on occasion meaning his
invulnerability is tied to being aware
of an attack as the time that he has
been surprised he's been susceptible to
attacks and even injured on the other
hand Thanos's primary weakness is in his
own mind during the Infinity Gauntlet
event his arrogance got the better of
him leading to Thanos leaving his
physical body you serving the world of
eternity as a noncorporeal form and
losing the gauntlet to nebula following
the Infinity Gauntlet event Dan else's
conversation with Adam warlock revealed
that Thanos himself doesn't believe he's
worthy of absolute power and is constant
failures and maintaining absolute power
are a result of this inner truth now
having said that the question is this
who would win if the two of them fought
well in previous videos where I would be
the one to answer that question I'll
actually leave it to you guys you guys
can either post here in the comment
section or you can head over to my
Twitter page a comics explained and I
have a poll set up there to let you vote
on which one will come out on top one
punch man or Thanos and I will catch you
guys later peace